autres manifestations en france celle
des livreurs à 0 ils protestent contre
la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
les livreurs des livres notamment aux
loyers ont bloqué les locaux de la
plateforme de livraison de plats
cuisinés les coursiers se sont réunis
pour dénoncer la baisse des tarifs
pratiqués par leur entreprise depuis
l'été 2010 9 l'entreprise aurait établi
si c'est minimum de livraison à moins de
trois euros par course
le collectif des livreurs autonomes
appellent à boycotter désormais
l'application d'écouté le peu de
personnes qui viennent ici c'est des
personnes qui parlent même pas français
donc en fait des libéraux a choisi son
camp quand il préfère une main d'oeuvre
s'est même pas qualifié mais sans
papiers qui va tout accepter qu'une main
d'oeuvre voilà car qui connaît ses
droits et qui a cassé papier qui qui se
révoltent pour des courses ou ou
ou le prier au taux horaire il vous
revient à peine 6 7 euros de l'heure en
brut vous enlevez tout ça sur toutes les
charges
voilà en fait en fait des libéraux a
choisi de prendre des autos des
indépendants pour pour se cacher devant
toutes les charges qu'ils ont à payer
quoi ça leur permet de ne rien payer et
qu'on est tous à payer à leur place mais
le souci c'est quoi c'est que si encore
le tarif est et descend le tarif des
courses
le taux horaire où on aurait intérêt à
une tarification minimum à la course on
sacrifierait on se dirait voilà on est
sacrifiée ont sacrifié pour ça le moment
non salaires derrière si on s'arrête de
travailler ben on est mort quoi en fait
on est mort en vrai parce que tu sais
qu'il peut gagner 500 euros par mois et
vivre c'est pas possible
vous allez demander à ce que tous ceux
qui viennent de commencer ou ceux qui
ont pas des stades parfaite
ils réservent leurs horaires à 17 heures
à 17 heures je viens tu prends les
restes je prends les restes tout le
monde est déjà passé par là à 15h et d
où 11 heures ceux qui ont des stats
parfaite ils réservaient leurs horaires
à 11 heures 11 heures du matin du
couvent passer avant tout le monde
vous prenez tous les horaires et ceux
qui arrivent à 17 heures mais ils ont
plus rien mais parce qu'ils n'ont pas
des stats parfaite
donc soit on est toujours là c'est pas
juste en fait c'est très juste de
meilleures conditions de travail pour
les personnes rémunérées à la tâche
c'est également ce que réclame eric
coquerel député la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis soutenir livre de
divers ou dans leur bataille pour la
reconnaissance de meilleures conditions
de travail d'un statut qui soit pas
celui d'un travail et à la tâche
permanent digne du 19e siècle
c'est une tâche c'est je veux dire c'est
un combat absolument centrale
et c'est normal que je savais à une des
premières mesures du quinquennat macron
ça a été de doubler le plafond des
entrepreneurs et donc de multiplier ces
gens qui n'ont pas de protection qu'on
peut appeler pour un oui pour un non à
internet telle tâche
et en plus de ça pour délit vo avec on
voit bien des dangers évidents de par
leur moyen de locomotion et cécilia pas
tout le monde ils doivent accélérer le
rythme pour gagner des derniers misère
bon voila moi je ne veux pas de retour
du 2e siècle si c'est ça le nouveau rond
ça m'intéresse pas